Halloween saw Wayne All Hallows Eve
whatever you call it it's known as the
time of year when the veil between the
land of the living and the spirit world
is at its thinnest it's the time of
things going bump in the night carving
pumpkins slipping on a rubbery mask and
getting ready to terrorize the
neighborhood whether you celebrate by
going door to door and extorting
strangers for candy staying in and
watching scary movies in your pajamas or
going out to wreck a little Havoc with
eggs and rolls of toilet paper just
about everyone likes to Mark the day
with a little bit of spooky fun the
folks at the SCP Foundation are no
exception sure they see plenty of
Horrors in their everyday lives but that
doesn't mean they've lost the holiday
spirit around Halloween staff can find
jack-o'-lantern shaped sugar cookies
waiting for them in the break room
alongside hot cider and there is a
yearly party in the canteen with holiday
Tunes bobbing for apples and even a
costume contest a but for some these
festivities don't quite cut it they're
not creepy spooky or ooky enough to
truly celebrate the scariest holiday by
some I of course mean Dr Jack Wright
everyone's favorite Immortal human
consciousness living inside an anomalous
necklace Dr bright was determined to
take last Halloween up a notch and he
gathered his supervisors together to
pitch his latest brilliant idea a
haunted house open for one night only
filled with frightening anomalies from
the SCP Foundation his request for
resources and permission to put the
haunted house together were swiftly
denied but Dr bright is nothing if not
determined without the use of official
funds he began plotting he tracked down
a venue a large abandoned Farmhouse a
few miles away from the site he found a
discount Halloween supply store and he
watched hours of crafting tutorials on
YouTube to put together the best the
scariest the most memorable House of
Horrors anyone had ever seen he planned
the launch of his haunted house
attraction to coincide perfectly with
the annual office party while his
colleagues were busy dancing the Monster
Mash and enjoying the apple cider Dr
bright was getting ready to open the
doors unveil his months of hard work and
scare the pants off of any customers who
dared step inside however in all his
preparations he had forgotten to spread
the word to the nearby community except
for an ad he purchased on Instagram so
when Dr Bryant's house of SCP [ __ ]
opened for business only three people
were waiting to purchase a ticket Janie
Maddie and Zach a group of high school
sophomores looking for something to do
before the Halloween party in the woods
later that night as the doors creaked
open Dr bright ushered the teens inside
with a wave of his hand he was dressed
up as Dracula complete with a cape and a
pair of plastic fangs when he spoke he
affected a comical vampire accent
welcome children prepare for nightmares
that will last a lifetime he waited for
his guests to acknowledge his incredible
performance but they just stared blankly
at him for a moment ah are you done
Janie asked Dr bright cleared his throat
suddenly self-conscious admission is
five dollars the three teen shrug and
handed over the money enjoy
he backed out of the room with a ghostly
whale okay bye Maddie called after him
follow me into the first room
Dr Bright's voice came from around the
corner I guess we just go that way Zach
followed the voice and his friends
joined him as they walked into a
makeshift laboratory where Dr Wright was
waiting the lights were dim a steel
table sat in the corner covered in
something dark red and wet in the
darkness a cloaked figure moved about
his face a long beaked mask his hands
covered in thick black gloves welcome
new patients to the lab of the plague
doctor Dr Brent declared behind him
scp-049 was performing an experiment on
the remains of a cow with a flip of a
switch on the wall a flash of
electricity crackled Illuminating the
room as the plague doctor looked up to
greet the newcomers oh welcome may I
show you what I've been working on he
held up a long gleaming scalpel is that
it Maddie remarked unimpressed I I think
that's it Zach replied kind of boring
Janie's side if he could the project
doctor would have frowned I am but a
humble man of science doing my work if
that is not sufficient for you then I
apologize it's fine doc don't worry Dr
bright opened the next door follow me
and have your spines tingled by the next
terrifying chamber ew the group of teens
laughed still they had already spent
five dollars on this thing might as well
see it through and tell everyone at the
party later about this weird man and his
awful haunted house Dr bright LED the
group down a long narrow hallway it
smelled of rotten wood and mildew the
carpet squishing unpleasantly beneath
their feet keep an eye on your
surroundings Dr bright called over his
shoulder we might not be alone in here
behind him the kids rolled their eyes
just don't touch the walls Dr bright
said ominously the group followed him
not the least bit nervous it was a
creepy old house but there was nothing
in here scarier than a cockroach as
Janie felt something crunched beneath
her shoes she stopped to take a look ugh
she groaned when she looked up she
noticed something strange black goo
dripping down the wall next to her God
this place has
she grimaced her friends turned to see
what made her fall behind and their eyes
widened Janie Maddie's voice wavered
slightly Zach pointed behind you Janie
spun around and was confronted with a
horrific figure
scp-106 was emerging from the
desiccating wall smiling at her with a
wide toothless grin his flat eyes filled
with malice she gasped but then stopped
oh it's just an old guy that's fine nice
try Grandpa follow me please move away
from the wall please Dr Wright was
beginning to regret bringing scp-106
into his attraction it seemed a bit too
dangerous now that he thought about it
quickly please okay what's next Maddie
linked arms with her friends pulling
them after their incredibly cringed tour
guide well you're about to find out if
you can handle it Dr bright opened the
door with a big sweeping gesture step
inside the kitchen of death oh what's
for dinner Jane equipped Doom Dr bright
grind the visitors and their guideline
walked into a dingy kitchen Rusty pots
hanging from the ceiling a wood stove
crackling in the corner something fuzzy
green and unidentifiable growing in the
sink the first thing that greeted the
group aside from the smell of meat
sizzling in the pan was the sound of a
bellowing male's Voice singing an
operatic Arya sure enough they're at the
stove wearing a chef's hat that appeared
comically tiny on his massive head was a
giant of a man singing he wore a
blood-stained apron reading kissed the
cook oh welcome who's hungry I've been
cooking all evening it's an odd recipe I
learned while studying under Julia Child
at their Culinary Academy a truly famous
dish I'm a nephew you know for then
child I keep our memory alive by
preparing my favorite meals of hers
though I didn't use chicken for this one
I selected a different protein the giant
man held out a serving spoon shoving it
into Zack's face what the taste Zach
recoiled no thanks man I'm a vegetarian
suit yourself more for the rest of us
any takers Ferdinand offered a spoon to
Maddie who shook her head then to Janie
who seemed to consider it for a moment
but then turned it down Ferdinand is
what I like to call a humanitarian Dr
bright quipped thank you sir I do enjoy
my charity work Fernand saluted him oh
and we do have another guest joining us
for dinner correct that's right though
she prepares for me rare So Rare in fact
Dr bright grinned wickedly that it's
still alive I've said the place for her
already Fernand gestured to a small
table where a plate held a large serving
of Raw Liver next to it an open bottle
of wine behind the little group a woman
swept through the door she was beautiful
but Eerie somehow her eyes glinted with
feral cleverness and under her thick
dark hair were a pair of fox ears a tail
switch behind her as she walked and her
fingernails were more like Jagged claws
did you start without me how rude her
voice had an edge to it the same vaguely
menacing inhuman quality that hung over
the rest of her she's pretty hot hi Zach
whispered shut up Matty I'll load him no
he's right she is Janie piped up the
woman barely acknowledged them instead
walking to her place at the table she
picked up the liver in her hands and
opened her mouth to reveal a naturally
sharp teeth then she dug in with
ravenous hunger of a caged animal that
had not been fed in far too long
terrifying isn't she Dr bright urged not
really Maddie shook her head what else
he got Zach raised an eyebrow meanwhile
the foxwoman had finished her meal and
moved on to the wine can I get some of
that genius no no underage drinking in
my haunted house only scarce Dr bright
sputtered fine whatever just follow me
he led the group onward leaving
Ferdinand and the polymorphic humanoid
to their strange cannibalistic dinner
party if you're in the mood for a meal
perhaps you'd like to watch a little
television Dr bright gave a villainous
cackle as he threw open the door to the
living room it was the least Eerie room
so far a standard living room if a bit
Dusty there was an overstuffed chair a
couch a coffee table a lamp in the
corner and a vintage TV set plonked down
in front of the couch how do do you all
feel about clowns Dr Brian asked oh no
no no no no no I hate clowns Janie's
face went pale oh it's gonna be fine
Maddie patted her shoulder now like
it'll actually be scary Zach's cough
don't be so sure check this out Dr
bright switched on the TV which began
playing an episode of scp-993 Bobble the
clown unfortunately for Dr bright but
fortunately for Janie he had forgotten
that scp-993 doesn't show its more
upsetting content to anyone over the age
of 10. the three teenagers immediately
collapsed unconscious oh damn it oh no
Dr Wright scrambled to switch the TV
back off as soon as the screen went
black the kids sat up disoriented and
rubbing their heads ah sorry about that
technical difficulties I mean um ooh
scary scary technical difficulties the
kids started him blankly
um Claudia a little help here the three
friends looked around expecting to see
someone else in the room with them but
there was no one are you you feeling
okay Maddie looked genuinely concerned
he's fine a voice piped up just behind
her are you Maddie spun around looking
for the source of the voice but there
was no one there oh I get it you've got
a hidden speaker in here or something
right nope the mysterious voice laugh
it's just me hey watch this suddenly
Janie's phone floated out of her pocket
hanging in the middle of the air as if
held by an invisible hand rude she
snatched it back pretty good I almost
didn't see the wires Zack smirk no wires
kid just me a cushion flipped off the
couch on its own the lamp tipped over on
its side the TV remote careened across
the room yawn Zach rolled his eyes he
came here to get scared not for basic
magic tricks you won't be so cocky when
you see the next Rome Dr bright grimaced
so show it to us then Maddie retorted I
will if you just go that way yeah that
door open it Dr Brightside blah blah
blah welcome to the infirmary Beware of
the patients they bite
go Dr bright LED the group into a string
strangely bright room a jarring contrast
to the rest of the house it was lit with
buzzing fluorescent lights and contained
absolutely no furniture as they walked
in they could hear the rattling of
chains but they couldn't make out the
source of the sound at first then a
figure lurched into view it looked like
a person but there was something
horribly wrong their skin was covered in
patches of yellow gangrenous tissue
Their Eyes Were glassy and vacant and
their mouth hung open in a slack empty
expression All Along The Wall there were
people chained up and straining steadily
against their bonds shuffling toward the
group as they drew closer okay zombies
classic I get it Zack frogged they're
kind of creepy Maddie shivered as one of
the creatures snapped its jaws at her he
couldn't get close enough to take a bite
but the intent felt real just the same
they're not real it's fine Jenny gave
Maddie's shoulder a comforting squeeze
I'm afraid these poor souls are indeed
all too real Dr Bright's energy was
restored as he saw a bit of fear
creeping into the group's sarcastic
demeanor victims of a comp complex prion
disease one with no known cure once they
were infected they were lost within a
day now their Hollow shells of their
former selves walking corpses with only
one goal to Devour the living sure
totally Zach laughed but his eyes
flickered nervously from zombie to
zombie the room smelled like Decay thick
and nauseating and these people didn't
seem like actors next room please
Maddie's voice shook betraying her
frazzled nerves but I haven't shown you
my favorite specimen yet over here Dr
bread led the group to a massive glass
tank where something fleshy and vaguely
humanoid was crouching inside it was
shaped almost like a person but as if
their body had begun to melt skin had
turned to something soft slick and slimy
looking a palm slapped wetly against the
glass when the group noticed that its
fingers looked webbed excess skin
growing between them and stretching out
making the digits look more like
tentacles than something human then it
looked at them or rather it turned its
face toward them the flesh had spread
over the place where the eyes nostrils
and mouth should have been instead it
was just smooth and blank all over for
the first time since they entered the
haunted house the three visitors had
nothing to say this is a particularly
awful disease highly contagious highly
aggressive thankfully it's been
contained mostly just don't tap on the
glass you might aggravate him then who
knows what I'll do with the creek he
opened the next door shall we the three
teens nodded silently and glancing over
their shoulders one more time at the
Eerie figure in the tank quickly
followed him out enjoy the change of
scenery Dr bright commented as he led
the group out of a side door back into
the crisp autumn air we're going out of
the main house to a greenhouse over here
we could use a little bit of nature
don't you think so killer plants or what
Zach guess you'll have to wait and see
Dr bright stopped at the entrance to a
large glass Greenhouse the glass dirty
and opaque from years of disuse prepare
yourselves it's a little swampy inside
in the greenhouse naturally there were
dozens of different plants Vines
creeping up the walls colorful flowers
blossoming Moss hanging down from the
ceiling the air was humid and hot a
jarring change after the cool night
Breeze just outside the floor was
flooded with a shallow layer of stagnant
water green pond scum resting along the
top these are new shoes Zac Brown does
his pristine sneakers disappeared into
the muck with a splash are there bugs in
here Maddie winced oh absolutely Dr
bright chuckled I hope you've all had
your Shots by the way what what's that
mean Janie demanded further explanation
but Dr bright provided none as they
trudged through the greenhouse the water
grew deeper climbing higher up their
legs until it reached their knees oh
what's that smell Janie pinched her nose
with a Grimace why don't you look over
there and see Dr bright pointed to an
area just ahead but the water was
Rippling curiously as if something was
just below the surface a dark patch of
Tangled greasy hair had slowly begun to
surface followed by a modded green face
large wide eyes stared at the group as
scp-811 emerged from the water you
hungry Dr bright asked she nodded
silently looking intently at the teens
they're not for you they're guests here
Dr bright produced a dead possum which
he threw toward the swamp woman she held
the carcass in place slowly melting it
with digestive fluid that leaks from all
of her slimy pores if I get sick from
this place my mom will sue you she's a
lawyer Jamie threatened let's uh move on
then we're almost at the finale Dr
bright and the kids left the swamp woman
to digest her meal and headed back
towards the main house follow me into
the basement careful it's dark down here
Dr bright flipped a switch and a single
dim flickering bulb illuminated the
rickety wooden stairs down into the
Blackness of the basement watch your
step who knows how stable these stairs
are as the group descended into the
depths of the house they could hear the
sound of some something sobbing softly
whatever it was it sounded positively
heartbroken at the foot of the stairs
off to the side they could see a tall
thin pale figure with a burlap bag over
its head its arms were wrapped around
itself and it was shaking so what he'll
pull the bag off and it's something
really scary Maddie cast oh no we won't
be touching that back if you value your
life you'll trust me when I say that's
not worth it he's plenty scary without
getting you all eviscerated for a creepy
basement this is pretty boring Janie's
side still the group continued to follow
Dr bright as they passed the shy guy in
the burlap sack getting further and
further away from the light of the
stairs the walkway began to narrow they
left the main room of the basement and
squeezed into a tight Stone pathway one
that forced them to walk in single file
one right behind the other they couldn't
hear the sobbing anymore couldn't hear
Dr bride making cheesy ghost noises or
trying to build up the atmosphere all
they could hear were their footsteps
their hearts beating and the sound of
their own breathing then they realized
there had been four sets of footsteps
but now they heard a fifth coming from
somewhere up ahead whatever it was it
was getting closer and closer and it
sounded big it sounded like nothing
they'd ever heard before just when the
tension was so palpable wound so tight
that they couldn't take it anymore Dr
bright clicked on a flashlight and
illuminated the monster that stood just
before then roar I am roll man a massive
furry creature stretched out its arms
filling the chamber and leaving No
Escape the kid screamed louder than they
ever had before and ran back the way
they came they sprinted up the stairs
back through each room and out the front
door as they sat on the grass outside
catching their breath Dr bright emerged
from the house he was beaming with pride
and he was clapping so I did it didn't I
I really scared you are you gonna do
this again next year Maddie asked
eagerly I wasn't impressed at first but
you really pulled it off Janie nodded uh
yeah it was pretty cool back Shrugged
you have no idea how happy I am to hear
that Dr bright smiled unfortunately I'm
not sure my bosses will let me get away
with this one again pretty sure I'm in
big trouble for doing it this time but
you three made it all worth it here
Janie reached into her pocket and pulled
out an egg we're gonna use this later if
the place sucked you earned it Dr bright
wiped a joyful tear from his eye
accepting the gift happy Halloween now
you'd better run along to that party
before it gets too late the creatures
are uh getting hungry as he watched the
three walk away heading off to make more
memories he felt a sense of satisfaction
no matter what the bosses did to punish
him or how many containment breaches
he'd risked that day he knew he'd given
those kids a Halloween they would never
forget now go check out scp-823 Carnival
of Horrors and scp-097 old Fairgrounds
for more terrifying attractions from the
world of the SCP Foundation